right i mean
don knuth who i know that you you've
interviewed as well right he
uh likes to conjecture that p equals np
but that the algorithm is so inefficient
that it doesn't matter anyway
right now i i don't know i've listened
to him say that i don't know
whether he says that just because he has
an actual reason for thinking it's true
or just because it sounds cool
yeah okay but um but you know that
that's a logical possibility right that
the algorithm could be
n to the 10 000 time or it could even
just be n
squared time but with a leading constant
of it could be a google times n
squared or something like that and in
that case the fact that p
equals np well it would it would uh
you know ravage the whole theory of uh
complexity we would have to you know
rebuild from the ground up
but in practical terms it might mean
very little right
if the algorithm was too inefficient to
run if the algorithm
could actually be run in practice like
if it had small enough constants
you know to or if you could improve it
to where it had
small enough constants that was uh
efficient in practice
then that would change the world okay
you think it would have like what kind
of impact
well okay i mean i mean here's an
example i mean you could well okay
just for starters you could break
basically all of the encryption
that people use to protect the internet
you could you could break bitcoin
and every other cryptocurrency or you
know uh
mine as much bitcoin as you wanted right
uh you know become a you know
become a a super duper billionaire right
and then
and then plot your next move right okay
that's just for starters right
right now your next move might be
something like
you know you now have like a
theoretically optimal way to train any
neural network
to find parameters for any neural
network right so you could now say like
is there any small neural network that
generates the entire content of
wikipedia
right if you know and now the question
is not can you find it
the question has been reduced to does
that exist or not yes if it does exist
then the answer would be yes you can
find it okay if
if if you had this algorithm in your
hands okay
you could ask your computer you know i
mean i mean p
versus np is one of these seven problems
that carries this million million-dollar
prize
from the clay foundation you know if you
solve it uh you know and
others are the riemann hypothesis uh the
punk array conjecture which was solved
although
the solver turned down the prize right
and uh and
and four others but what i like to say
the way that we can see that p versus np
is the biggest of all of these questions
is that
if you had this fast algorithm then you
could solve all seven of them
okay you just ask your computer you know
is there a short proof of the riemann
hypothesis
right you know that that a machine could
in a language where a machine could
verify
it and provided that such a proof exists
then your computer finds it
in a short amount of time without having
to do a brute force search
okay so i mean i mean those are the
stakes of what we're talking about
but i hope that also helps to give your
listeners some intuition
of why i and most of my colleagues would
put our money on p not equaling np
you